رسم بالحناء واغاني
وهزيج تراثيه وشعبيه اردنيه
وكذلك سعوديه في حفل حناء رجوه خطيبه ولي
العهد الاردنيه الذي اقيم في الديوان
الملكي الهاشمي بالفعل تفاعل واسع شهده
الحفل عبر مواقع التواصل مع مشاركه الملكه
رانيا العبد الله فرحتها ومع كلمتها
الخاصه لكنها رجوى اليوم بنفرح باحلى رجوه
ستكون اذا وقفتنا الاخباريه الاولى من
الاردن مع سهى جميله التي حضرت الحفل لكن
قبل الحديث مع سهى لنشاهد هذه المقاطع
ومشاعر الفرح في العائله الملكيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هي احلى رجاء مني لرب العالمين لحسين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جد غلاوتها من غلاوه ايمان وسلمى
عزه انا بعرف انا كنت بمحلك قبل شهرين
وبعرف انت كيف شعري بس بدي اطمنك انه رجوى
بعيوننا وبعيون حسين وهي بين اهلها وناسها
فاطمئني عليها
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات